[Musique]
vers mi mai qu'on a remarqué l'arrivée
des militaires juste après la la frappe
de dia liste dans le nord qui sont
arrivés depuis lors on lui met la
présence des militaires un peu partout
dans la ville les rues marque un peu
partout et il ya des patrouilles toutes
les nuits
[Musique]
on a trop peur avec la situation nous
vend des clés en emprunts de le prendre
puisque à sémalens ne sais pas qui à qui
on a trop peur un peu le matin comme ça
on peut sentir avant qu'alain à ce qu'il
était avant tout sorti en plus on peut
travailler au moins 5000 à 6000 mais
aujourd'hui de laquelle un ce qu'il
était vraiment ça ne va pas quand on
reçoit même des fois même du cinéma
ramené de 1000 francs à la maison
[Musique]
l'état d'urgence va permettre à
l'administration aux forces de défense
et de sécurité d'avoir un peu plus de
souplesse dans leur activité de faire
des contrôles
identitaire un peu plus fréquent de
faire des contrôles domicile hier
d'interdire certaines activités et on le
sait l'état de d'urgence sécuritaire va
entraîner un fléchissement les libertés
individuelles et collectives